[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the cast members of harry
potter specifically we're going to be
addressing what the iconic harry potter
cast full of superstars is doing now
when we think of the harry potter films
it's hard to believe that the most
recent installment came out over a
decade ago with the deathly hallows part
2 hitting the silver screen
in 2011
but if that doesn't sound like a long
time ago then it may surprise you to
hear that the first installment the
philosopher's stone came out a decade
before that in 2001
but while it's been quite some time
since we've seen the original cast in
action they did give us 10 years of
great movies which i'll be forever
grateful for
today i'm going to be exploring what
your favorite characters 50 of them for
that matter are up to in a post harry
potter world
what have they achieved in their acting
careers personal lives during these past
11 years let's get into it 1. horace
loghorn jim broadbent
hogwarts lovable potions professor and
head of southern house was played by
actor jim broadbent who before and after
harry potter had an illustrious acting
career broadbent who first joined the
cast in 1996 for the half-blood prince
has since starred in a multitude of
popular films tv shows including but
certainly not limited to
the iron lady a film about xpm margaret
thatcher where he plays her husband
dennis thatcher opposite meryl streep as
well as game of thrones where he plays
archmeister ebros
2. sirius blank gary oldman when it
comes to the harry potter cast it's hard
to imagine a career more successful or
dynamic than that of gary oldman who
plays harry's godfather and marauder
sirius black
since harry potter ended he's been
involved in a multitude of films
including but not limited to
dawn of the planet of the apes rover cop
darkest hour where he plays winston
churchill and the dark knight rises
where he plays commissioner gordon
3. dudley dursley harry melling dudley
desley harry's awful cousin who spent
his youth making harry's life miserable
was played by an actor who incidentally
is called harry himself harry melling
while melling seemingly disappeared
after the harry potter films had ended i
was delighted to see him in tv's the
queen's gambit where he plays yet
another harry harry baltic
4. ginny weasley bonnie wright ginny
weasley weasley family member and
harry's love interest was played by
actress bonnie wright
as it turns out shortly after the harry
potter films had ended wright created
her own film production company bonbon
lumiere where she has since been able to
stretch her skill set outside the
confines of a traditional actor
while wright has starred in some tv film
works she seems to have shifted her
focus even more towards directing and
screenwriting in more recent years
5. lucius malfoy jason isaacs
lucius malfoy who is draco's dad and one
of the slimiest characters in the series
is played by actor jason isaacs
since completing his time as a harry
potter cast member isaacs has been very
active in the acting circuit taking on
roles in other star-studded film
franchises tv series including star trek
and star wars however that barely
scratches the surface of isaac's acting
resume 6. garrick ollivander john hurt
garrick ollivander who doles out wands
to the young witches and wizards in the
wizarding world
was played by iconic british actor john
hurt
tragically hurt passed away in 2017 but
over the course of his life and career
is very clear that he certainly wasn't
short of accolades after the last harry
potter he landed roles in popular tv
series including merlin labyrinth and
the last panthers among others
7. ron weasley rupert grint
ron weasley of the weasley clan and
harry's best friend is played by actor
rupert grint
since the harry potter films ended grint
has landed numerous acting roles in
television film my favorite being sick
notes where he plays daniel glass
alongside co-star nick frost you may be
also surprised to hear that grint is now
a father having welcomed his first
daughter along in may of 2020
eight voldemort rafe fines lord
voldemort one of the best villains in
film history was played by none other
than rafe fines
since harry potter ended vines has been
involved in a number of theatrical
productions as well as some popular
films including the king's man the grand
budapest hotel and recent james bond
films where he plays the iconic role of
m
9. remus lupin david thulis
remus lupin marauder werewolf and
one-time data professor was played by
iconic british actor david thewlis
since harry potter ended thules has been
involved in various film tv projects
including the theory of everything which
outlines the life of theoretical
physicist stephen hawking wonder woman
and 2022's the sandman among many others
10. sybil trelawny emma thompson
if we're going to talk about iconic
british actors then we of course can't
forget emma thompson who played sybil
trelawny hogwarts questionable
divination professor since harry potter
ended emma has been involved in a
multitude of projects including but not
limited to
men in black saving mr banks and bridget
jones
11. mcgonagall maggie smith maggie smith
who plays hogwarts transfiguration
professor and later headmistress minerva
mcgonagall has fairly openly expressed
her disinterest in discussing the harry
potter series in more recent years which
is why it should come as no surprise
that she has embraced other projects the
most notable probably being downton
abbey where she plays violet crawley
12. dumbledore richard harris michael
gambon
dumbledore hogwarts headmaster and
powerful wizard was originally played by
actor richard harris but after he
tragically passed away in 2002 the role
was reprised by actor michael gambon
since harry potter ended gambon has been
featured in many shows films including
the pbs miniseries little women victoria
and abdul kingsman the golden circle
dan's army and judy
13. phillies flitwick warwick davis
warwick davis plays professor filius
flitwick in the harry potter films also
less notably griphook flipwick's
character was known for many things his
mastery of dueling his teaching of
charms and perhaps most notably being
the head of ravenclaw house
since harry potter ended davis has
featured in a number of films tv shows
including doctor who and various
projects inside of the star wars
franchise
14. aberforth dumbledore aberforth
dumbledore the brother of hogwarts
headmaster albus dumbledore was played
by actor kieran hinz
since harry foster ended hinz has
featured a number of films tv shows
including rome game of thrones and
shetland
15. weasley twins the mischievous
weasley twins fred and george weasley
were played respectively by actors james
and oliver phelps
since harry potter ended the actors have
continued to work together starring in
various television acting roles
however it appears that the pair have
also branched out from traditional media
by starting their own podcast normal not
normal
16. fleur de la cour clemens posey
fleur de la cour fierce tri-wizard
tournament contestant and later wife to
bill weasley was played by actress
clemence posey
since harry potter ended posey has
continued to thrive in her successful
modelling career while simultaneously
landing roles in big name films such as
tenet
17. james finnegan devin murray james
finnegan the young gryffindor who had a
knack for blowing things up was played
by irish actor devin murray since harry
potter ended murray appears to have
weaned off of film television and
instead seems to be focusing on his
family life
in 2018 murray began dating shannon
quinn and in 2021 they welcomed their
son cooper 18. draco malfoy tom felton
draco malfoy harry's rival and
slytherin's poster boy was played by
british actor tom felton
since harry potter surrendered felton
has appeared in number of indie films
and television programs including from
the rough and the apparition however it
would be criminal not to mention
felton's massive success on social media
platforms particularly tick tock at one
point draco obsessed fans began using
the hashtag dracotalk which became
massively viral
19. narcissa malfoy helen mcquarrie
narcissa malfoy wife of lucius mother of
draco and sister of bellatrix was played
by british actress helen mccrory
tragically mccrory just passed away last
year
in the years after harry potter had
ended mcquarrie found a great deal of
success in various film projects
television programs including hugo james
bond skyfall and peaky blinders
r.i.p helen
20. ruby's handgrid robbie coltrane
hogwarts keeper of keys and grounds and
harry's protector rubius hagrid was
played by actor robbie coltrane
since harry potter ended coltrane has
toned down the workload and is only
featured in a handful of projects
including channel 4 series national
treasure as well as pixar's brave where
he voices lord dingwall
21. cormac mclagan freddie stromer
cormac mclagan the insufferable
gryffindor student and quidditch player
known to drop his family name at the
drop of a hat was played by actor
freddie stromer since harry potter ended
stroma has featured in a number of film
projects tv shows including pitch
perfect game of thrones the inbetweeners
and bridgeton
22 rita skeeter miranda richardson
rita skeeter poison piece expert and
journalist intent on making everyone
look bad was played by actress miranda
richardson
since harry potter ended richardson has
featured in a number of tv mini-series
including but not limited to rubicon
parade's end world without end and good
omens
23. bellatrix helena bonham carter
bellatrix lestrange voldemort's infamous
right-hand woman was expertly played by
actress helena bonham carter
based on the insanity of her character
one might assume that it would require
an actress who at least loosely
resembled this character however carter
is certainly not insane and this is just
a testament to her acting ability
since harry potter surrendered carter
has continued to play other strange and
demanding characters with roles in dark
shadows les miserables alice through the
looking glass and cinderella
24. cornelius fudge robert hardy
cornelius fudge everyone's least
favorite minister for magic and infamous
voldemort denier was played by actor
robert hardy
hardy tragically passed away in 2017 at
the age of 91 but it should be noted
that hardy impressively worked until the
day that he died
after harry potter had ended hardy
appeared in tv series little dorit tv
movie churchill and short joseph's real
25. dolores umbridge imelda staunton
delores umbridge tyrant of hogwarts
students and staff and probably harry
potter's best bad guy was expertly
played by actress imelda staunton
since harry potter ended stormton has
featured in a number of film television
projects including maleficent downton
abbey and the crown where she plays
queen elizabeth ii
i know you all hate unbridge but don't
direct that anger and staunton
26. gilderoy lockhart kenneth branagh
gilderoy lockhart order of merlin third
class honorary member of the dark force
defense league and five-time winner of
which weekly's most charming smile award
was expertly played by actor kenneth
branagh many of you may not know this
but branagh in addition to being an
extremely accomplished actor is also a
very well respected director and writer
after the harry potter series came to an
end bran are featured as an actor in
many popular films including dunkirk
tenet and murder on the orient express
which he also happened to direct
27. harry potter daniel radcliffe
the man the whole story is based around
harry potter was expertly played by
actor daniel radcliffe
provided that daniel's role is
synonymous with the films you'd think
that he would have been typecast as
harry forever
and if you thought that you're probably
still right
however radcliffe a truly dedicated
actor clearly has ambitions of
transcending being just harry potter as
he has starred featured in many films
since the harry potter films came to an
end
since harry potter ended radcliffe has
tried his hand at broadway
starring in the broadway musical how to
succeed in business without really
trying as well as featured in numerous
films including but not limited to the
woman in black now you see me too and
the lost city
but in what i feel will be his best
performance yet aside from harry of
course radcliffe will be starring in the
upcoming weird al yankovic biopic
playing weird al himself
28. argus filch david bradley
argus filch hogwarts resident caretaker
and second half to mrs norris was played
by actor david bradley since harry
potter ended bradley has been extremely
active in the film tv industry which is
particularly impressive if we consider
the fact that he's now 80 years old he's
been involved in a multitude of
successful tv series since harry potter
ended including afterlife game of
thrones doctor who and wizards at 80 he
doesn't seem to be slowing down either
may bradley be an inspiration to us all
29. arthur weasley mark williams
arthur weasley kind patient and caring
father of the impressively large weasley
family was played by actor mark williams
since harry potter ended williams has
found a considerable amount of success
in the long-running bbc tv series father
brown where he plays the main character
the series is currently nine seasons
strong and looks as though it may be
back for more
30. molly weasley julie walters molly
weasley mother of the weasley clan and
destroyer of bellatrix estranged was
played by actress julie walters
after harry potter ended walters among
many other things reprised her role in
the mamma mia films played mrs bird in
paddington and played mrs medlock in the
secret garden
31. severus snape alan rickman
zevra snape one of the most iconic grey
characters in all of film was expertly
played by the late alan rickman
rickman tragically passed away in 2016
but for five years after the last harry
potter film came out continued to grace
us with his acting in a multitude of
projects
these projects included films like a
little chaos gambit and a promise
i think it's safe to say that alan
rickman will be remembered by harry
potter fans always
32 kingsley shacklebolt george harris
kingsley shakabold order of the phoenix
member and later minister for magic was
played by actor george harris
in recent years it appears that harris
has kept a relatively low profile
seemingly enjoying the fruits of his
success
since harry potter ended harris has only
appeared in a few episodes of tv
miniseries
including sinbad and star hunter redux
33. pomona sprouts miriam margulies
pomona sprout hogwarts herbology
professor and head of hufflepuff house
was played by actress miriam margolies
since the end of harry potter margulies
is featured in many popular tv shows
films including merlin doc martin call
the midwife and the guilt trip to name a
few
34. miley granger emma watson hermione
granger harry's trusty friend in ron's
later love interest is played by none
other than emma watson
after the harry potter films had ended
watson went on to achieve many great
things both inside and outside of the
world of acting
in addition to starring in several films
including beauty and the beast the perks
of being a wallflower and bling ring
watson was also able to graduate from
brown university with a bachelor's
degree in english literature
in adulthood watson has also helped
leverage her platform in order to serve
as an advocate for gender equality
35. percy weasley chris rankin
percy weasley aka the least popular
weasley child was played by actor chris
rankin
since harry potter it appears as though
rankin has slowed down the workload
somewhat having worked on only a few
projects these projects include turtle
wipeout the stone and the wizard of oz
36. oliver wood sean biggerstaff
oliver wood captain and keeper for the
gryffindor quidditch team was played by
actor sean bigestaff
since harry potter ended bigger staff
has featured in numerous short films as
well as a few regular length films and
tv programs
these films tv programs include mary
queen of scots urban myths and super
november
37. petunia dursley fiona shaw
petunia dursley harry's despicable but
possibly very misunderstood and was
played by actress fiona shaw
since harry potter ended shaw has
featured in a multitude of tv series
including true blood mrs wilson baptiste
and killing eve
38. pansy parkinson
pansy parkinson the poster girl for
slytherin was most recently played by
actress scarlett byrne
since harry potter ended burn has
featured in a number of tv series
including the vampire diaries falling
skies and runaways
byrne is married to cooper hefner son of
hugh hefner
39. nymphadora tonks natalia tenor
nymphadora tonks wife of remus and brave
order of the phoenix member was played
by actress and musician natalia tenna
since harry potter rendered tenner has
featured in many popular tv programs
including game of thrones the
mandalorian and origin
40. bill weasley domino gleeson
bill weasley gringott's curse breaker
and the husband of fleur de la cour was
played by british actor domino gleeson
the son of mad eye moody actor brandon
gleason since harry potter ended gleason
has found an incredible amount of
success in both tv
and film
gleason notably plays general hux in
star wars the rise of skywalker
41. dean thomas alfred enoch dean thomas
a fellow gryffindor in harrazia who
eventually joins dumbledore's army was
played by actor alfred enoch after harry
potter enoch went on to star in abcs how
to get away with murder
[Music]
cho chang keti liang
cho chang a raven cool student in one of
harry's first love interests is played
by actress katie liang
since harry potter ended liang has kept
her workflow fairly steady featuring in
a different tv program or film every
year or so
these films and tv programs include
trainspotting the foreigner locked down
and tv series strangers
43. neville longbottom matthew lewis
actor matthew lewis played the mild
natured and later exceedingly courageous
neville longbottom a proud gryffindor
after harry potter ended lewis made his
on-stage debut in 2012 when he featured
in the play our boys
lewis also went on to star and feature
in a multitude of films and tv shows
in more recent years lewis has found
considerable success in his role as hugh
holton in tv series all creatures great
and small
44. moaning myrtle shirley henderson
moaning myrtle a ravenclaw student
killed by slytherin's basilisk under a
young tom little's orders was played by
actress shirley henderson
in the last decade anderson is featured
in a number of tv programs including
happy valley the nest and south cliff
45. luna lovegood ivana lynch
actress ivana lynch plays luna lovegood
the eccentric ravenclaw student who is
known for peculiar behavior since harry
potter lynch has appeared in a handful
of projects including the bbc drama
silent witness irish independent film my
name is emily and comedy gbf
46. xenophilius lovegood rhys ephons
xenophilius lovegood the bizarre father
of lunar lovegood and editor of the
quibbler was played by actor rhys ephans
since harry potter ended ephons has gone
on to appear in numerous films including
the king's man spider-man and snowden
for some reason i always get rhys
confused with paul bettany does that
happen to anyone else
47. katie bell
casey bell gryffindor student and
gryffindor quidditch chaser was played
by actress georgina leonidas since harry
potter ended leonidas seems to have
divided her time fairly equally between
theater film and television
she notably appears in the film
papadopoulos and sons television program
father brown alongside mark williams and
a theatrical production of beauty and
the beast
48. madaimudi brendan gleeson
madai moody order of the phoenix member
and famous dark wizard catcher is played
by actor brendan gleeson father of bill
weasley actor dominic gleason
since harry potter ended gleason has
found considerable success in television
with long-standing roles in both state
of the union as well as mr mercedes
49. victor crum stanislav yanevsky
victor crum bulgarian and seeker for the
bulgarian national quidditch team was
played by actor stanislav yanevsky
since harry potter ended yanevsky has
only appeared in a few television film
projects including resistance last man
down and undercover
50. battle twins the patil twins parvati
and padma were played by actresses
shafali chudari and afshan azad
since harry potter ended shefali went on
to act in films such as i am the doorway
heist jane and odilo fabia
afshan azad hasn't appeared in any tv
programs or films since harry potter but
has established herself quite well as a
social media personality
and that's it for this video this video
was a lot of fun to make has allowed me
to research so many of my favorite
actors
i can tell you that my list of films to
watch has grown a lot were you surprised
by any of this anything important that i
missed then be sure to leave a comment
down below
until next time remember there is plenty
to be learned even from a bad teacher
what not to do how not to be
[Music]
[Music]
you